on avait un preneur d'otages retranché
qui retenait sa fille en otage et qui
tournait autour du pot on avait du mal à
comprendre ce qui se passait comprend
qu'elle était là le fond de son problème
mais il refusait de sortir et il menacé
sasa jeune fille est donc on a dû
trouver un moyen de le lui faire
accepter qu'on comprenait son point de
vue et j'ai utilisé ce qu'on appelle
l'effet barnum c'est à dire que j'ai
utilisé un une acception général quelque
chose dont je pense qu'il va qui va le
prendre comme une de ces vérités en lui
disant voilà je sais que vous avez vécu
certainement des choses très difficiles
je sais que dans votre vie vous avez
vécu les injustices et il m'a dit oui
vous avez raison j'ai vécu les
injustices et la gelée si c'est
difficile ça fait mal on vous a trahi
c'est ça absolument matt rimer mais vous
avez tout compris on vous a trahis et
c'est quelqu'un de très proche qui vous
a trahis mais c'est tout à fait ça vous
savez je peux pas comprendre ce que vous
ressentez parce que je suis par votre
place mais je peux comprendre que vous
soyez extrêmement blessé de ce qui s'est
passé un peu ce que font certains
certains manipulateurs notamment à
certains tacles de voyance où on va
aller chercher une information on va là
la modifier pour vous la présentez d'une
autre façon et on va utiliser des
truismes des choses sur lesquelles il
est difficile de dire non à l'utilisant
ce mode de fonctionnement on va créer la
relation apathique très très vite on va
l'amener à baisser un petit peu la garde
c'est la manipulation donc éthiquement
parlant je les fais parce que l'enjeu
était important et qui avait un enjeu
vital
[Musique]
alors une belle négociations c'est 80%
de préparation les 1% d'agilité
d'importants d'improvisation organisée
on se prépare d'abord mentalement bien
évidemment il ya un principe en
négociations il n'y a pas de bonne
réponse
il ya de bonnes questions il n'y a que
des bonnes questions et donc on va se
poser des questions clés qu'on retrouve
dans tout les niveaux d'ailleurs qu'elle
soit face à un forcené qu'elle soit face
à nos enfants qu'elle soit ça c'est un
collaborateur ou un client les questions
sur quel pouvoir j'ai quand je négocie
avec lui qu'est ce qu'elle l'algiz
légitimité qu'ils me donnent quand je
négocie jusqu'où je souhaite aller
mentionné très préparée mentalement
techniquement avant on est capable de
s'adapter à certains moments il ya des
sujets qui sont négociables qu'on peut
discuter sur lesquels on peut transiger
et d'autres qui ne sont pas négociables
sur lesquels on ne va pas revenir
c'est important de commencer à les y en
a en tête les sujets qui ne sont pas
négociables
[Musique]
c'est la relation qui fait la
négociation sans création d'une relation
efficace n'y a pas de négociation est un
des éléments de la relation efficace
c'est la confiance
c'est le sujet fondateur de tout un tas
de situations et notamment aux
négociations pas de confiance pas de
relation pas de relation pas de
négociation possible on peut négocier
avec n'importe qui même avec un
terrorisme avec un criminel il faut
qu'ils aient un minimum de rapports de
confiance
[Musique]
xi a pas d'objectif pour ma partager ya
pas de négociations si je veut négocier
une augmentation de salaire ou quoi que
ce soit avec mon employeur
la première chose à faire c'est
verbaliser l'ocp l'objectif commun
partagé quels objectifs vous avez et que
l'objectif lui a à vous avoir dans
l'équipe et a travaillé dans l'équipe
c'est à dire que vous avez tous les deux
intérêt à trouver une solution
ça paraît tout bête mais la
verbalisation de l'objectif comme à
partager c'est ce qui permet de passer
de la compétition c'est à dire en
gagnant et un perdant à la coopétition
qu'est ce qu'on va gagner ensemble
en chaque en faisant un pas vers l'autre
et en trouvant le moyen d'arriver à un
accord qui satisfait chacun chacun
d'entre nous anti pathos je vois les
motions de lot mais je la refuse par
exemple dire à quelqu'un qui est en
colère calmez vous même si j'ai envie
qu'il se calme lui dire calmez-vous
c'est nier le droit qu'il a à être en
colère
en face à quelqu'un qui est en colère on
accepte sur l'émotion écoutez je peux
comprendre que vous soyez en colère au
vu de la situation mais je ne peux pas
vous laisser me parler sur ce ton
c'est à dire que je dise aussi l'émotion
du comportement
[Musique]
prenez les négociations de donald trump
par exemple c'est pas la négo il a écrit
un livre sur les techniques de
négociation mais c'est tout sûr de la
négociation j'impose mon point de vue à
l'autre je lui met la pression que lui
tord le bras et dès lors qu'ils
acceptent sous la contrainte
mon point de vue j'ai considéré qu'on a
négocié pas du tout le rapport de forces
est une technique de négociation mais
c'est pas celle que nous prônons nous
négociateurs professionnels parce que ça
casse l'image de la négociation pour moi
une négociation doit satisfaire toutes
les parties prenantes